sur cette île de trous se co
propriétaire d'un centre de tir de
l'outaouais nous présentent les armes
qui sont dans la mire du gouvernement
trudeau une carabine maximum physique ou
ottawa dévoile les montants qu'ils
proposent d'offrir aux propriétaires
d'armes dites d'assaut de type militaire
interdite alors par exemple de 1337
dollars pour un modèle à erez jusqu'à
6000 209 $ pour un ss g550 plus
sophistiqués dans certains cas ces prix
ne tiennent pas compte de tous les coûts
encourus par les propriétaires qui sont
nombreux à modifier leurs armes déplore
pierre farah caveau pas mal plus cher
qu'à qu'est ce qu'on a fait avant l'
acheter faire casser ce qui est du monde
qui vont extrêmement déçu combien ce
programme de rachat obligatoire
coûtera-t-il au trésor public difficile
d'évaluer avec certitude puisqu'on ne
sait pas combien de ces armes sont en
circulation
le directeur parlementaire du budget
estime et en 2021 que la mesure pourrait
coûter jusqu à 756 millions de dollars à
l'état cher mais nécessaire selon les
militants pour le contrôle des armes
les programmes de rachat obligatoire ont
fait leurs preuves dans d'autres pays
selon cet expert en australie ça a très
bien fonctionné donc ramené au dessus de
6 ans les larmes
entre les mains du bandama les opposants
au programme juge que l'interdiction
cible injustement les propriétaires
légitimes et non les criminels ils
préviennent que des propriétaires
prendront l'argent du rachat pour se
procurer d'autres modèles de fusil
semblables qui ne figure pas sur la
liste d'interdiction est définitivement
un
modèle qui m'en sortir et à d'autres
modèles existants présentement vers
lesquels ccc la parlement dirais non on
prendrait quel problème empêche de
rapporter une faille qu'il faut corriger
selon le groupe poly se souvient il
réclame une interdiction basée sur les
caractéristiques d'une arme plutôt
qu'une liste de modèles jugé facile à
contourner
en attendant les propriétaires visés
doivent choisir entre rendre leurs armes
en échange d'une compensation
ou la rendre inutilisable aux frais du
gouvernement
il y en a plusieurs qui m'ont dit qu'il
retournerait pas de ram d'être là à voir
qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'est ce qu'ils
vont faire je ne sais pas le programme
de rachats devraient être mises en
oeuvre d'ici la fin de l'année les
propriétaires ont jusqu'au 30 octobre
2023 pour se conformer à l'interdiction
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa